Check out the drip. Oh, what's that sort of emotion? Oh, I was trying to show the hoodie but hold on, hold on, easy, easy.
This can go horribly wrong very quickly. Oh, it's me, me, me, me. Oh, oh, but what's that? What's this? Take the back, take the back.
Oh, I'm trying so hard. I can't do this any more awkward. I'm literally on a diagonal in a vertical world.
And also, also, just before anyone comments, yes, I'm insecure about my socks, okay?
Why am I insecure? Do you see the little bubbles? That means I've worn these socks tons, okay?
So don't point out that my socks have all the bubbles on them. I'm insecure, okay?
So don't move. Is that stain on the blanket? It's not that fucking terrible.
I don't know if you can see the shadow. Do you see that shadow? That's the microphone. You guys don't make pumping ASMR?
Oh, shade.
Nasty socks and this is exact.
Where is the canister?
I'm used to start the canister. There's no pee. I repeat, there's no pee.
But we've got water to mix with the poop and popping. And there's a marvel to motion with cola.
Does cola drink in one's fortune? I fell in love with it.
Oh, it's that one character.
Yep, that one character in Marvel.
I'm out of milk. I need to go to the shop.
I ran out of milk last night.
Oh, sorry. Oh, no, it's not ASMR. Get fucked.
I can make all the loud noises. I won't get shagged.
Actually, I can make all the loud noises. It's because I've got an ASMR and I just do the rest of this and I'm never acting.
Unfortunately, I'm not going to glue my fake nails on because the glue and the manicure are still stuck on my fingernails.
I am like glistening, but not the good kind. There is good kind of glistening. This is not it.
How long since last shower?
I think yesterday. I put deodorant on because I was putting on the merchandise. I don't want to get it covered in bio.
Let's be honest. I'm not washing the clothes last to the stream. I'm taking them off again and we'll put other clothes.
Well, long story short, I have to put clothes on to stream. Okay? I've said it. I've said it. I don't normally do my things.
How was your five hours of sleep?
I've got three. I've got three. I have had three hours for years.
Things are happening. Oh my god, I'm sorry. I forgot to do the dance.
Unfortunately, I've had three hours of slumber, but I have fantastic news update-wise, ASMR-wise.
I think I could do not have about eight ASMR audios on the way. I'm not even kidding.
We normally don't wear clothes. No, I don't go outside, so it's not necessary. Three is not enough to go back to sleep.
It took me so long to put my stream up.
Right, so, you didn't know? I hit VTuber, Jimmy Bezu, my gen mate. She did a pop and cooking stream.
And when I was buying my American snacks in that shop, I saw this.
And I was like, wait a minute. Ain't this what Emmy did?
Like, this is genuinely what Emmy did. So, shout out to Emmy. Thank you for the inspiration.
It's a goofy hand cam stream. You know how much this cost me?
$9.95 AUD. Shot in Behaviour.
Bro, ask for an underword check. Did you record this all night?
I was doing a lot of behind-the-scenes things that can't come into fruition yet.
You must give me two months. Two months.
I was fixing my donathon as well. There's a lot of things that were outdated or unachievable.
I wasn't right, so I'll open up, then we're gonna be doing loads of stuff that you won't see the fruition for.
Until it's over, and all that jazz.
That's it.
Okay, I think I'm supposed to cut this in a very particular way, because Emmy cut it in a particular way.
Okay, it's a dinner plate. Don't get too excited now.
Don't, Joff, it's going to get too excited. A lot of reeds wind up.
It's got pop and cooking on the top.
Right. I need to cut it a certain way, or did I make that up?
There's, oh, who goes there? There's leaves and cuttons.
Hold on, there is a box of instructions. Let's pretend I understand the instructions.
One cup of rice, water, one quarter, one plastic of water to make the fake rice, roll it into an egg,
put it on a fried egg, or...
I'm gonna need to know what's inside before I even have a excuse to do what's going on here.
I'm gonna open it like this, and maybe regret it.
Okay, no, it's actually working out, and I'll hold on there.
Oh, I've got my next week's schedule.
Do you want to see next week's schedule right now?
I need to stand up and do it so you can see my feet.
If this toy suffers, it's actually edible.
But there's going to be cat hair in it, so it's up to you if you want to eat it or not.
Okay, look. Okay, cute.
Whoa, this is a lot more complex than I...
Why are they giving me an empty cheese slice?
Why would they give me an empty cheese slice?
Where's the cheese? If you're gonna give me it, at least give me the fucking cheese.
The volume's a bit lower than usual.
It's probably the microphone.
Wait, hold on, I'll turn that. This is a bit...
Sorry, if you can see the shadow cast, I'm having to talk like this.
No, this is very hard.
Oh, it's a mixing bag.
Do you want me to artificially turn myself off?
Because I'm screaming right now. I'm screaming in a room.
Oh, there's a spoon. That's so cute.
Oh my gosh, there's like sprinkles and everything.
Oh my gosh, that reflective surface for a V-tuber?
I can't believe it.
It would be so selfish, reflective surface.
What do we got going on here today, Johnny?
Thank you, reverse, for the super chat.
We don't pop and cook in. I have no idea what I'm doing.
Baby spoon. Baby spoon.
I've got my volume maxed out.
Right, I'm going to artificially turn myself up.
Okay, I'm going to turn the knob.
The knob has been turned.
The knob's been turned, right.
Okay, what is this? Did Emmy cut this up?
I think she did.
I think...
There's a musical note here.
There's a four leaf clover here.
And then I assume this is the water one?
Five cc's of water.
She cut it up, but you don't have to.
Okay, learning.
So what's the deal?
The yellow packet and one water.
Okay, I can do that.
But where do I make it?
There's like a bit of dirt in here.
It's not looking good.
Where am I?
Okay, I'm supposed to put the yellow one in here, so I'm going to do it.
Unless it has English on it, that tells me don't do that.
Cream dual powder.
Okay, and it's 100% as you're all my witness.
Yellow.
Yellow. Red.
Red, green, blue.
This is too complex for three hours of sleep.
This is a bit too much.
Okay.
I heard there were kittens.
A Gimli might come in.
She's a bit nervous.
I didn't like anything being done.
Slightly different than...
I don't think I'm doing this one.
Oh, whoa, that smells so sweet!
So gross.
What do you mean this is just...
I mean, it wasn't going to taste savory.
Put it that way.
Sorry, that was a really dumb statement.
Oh, it's sweet and it's sugar.
Well, it's not going to be bacon, is it?
It's not spamming a can, is it?
Oh my God, that is...
It's fumigating the rim.
That is really strong.
Okay.
The powder does get everywhere.
Bro, the...
Wait, so it wants this tiny droplet of water?
Like, there's nothing to it.
That's five CCs, it says.
Put one five CC.
I put all of the powder as my guess.
Okay, this is the yellow section.
I don't know why you would only put each E sashie in it
instead of two sashies.
If you want their English instructions...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're going to do this like men.
And do men ask for instructions when needed?
No.
Men stumble around
and get to the answer in the end.
They get the job done.
It doesn't have to be 100%,
but we're going to do this like men.
Do you understand me?
Men, because we're real men.
We are stumbling around
and we're going to have a good time, okay?
I don't even know what I'm making.
Please show me a picture, so my brain...
What?
I thought I was making something that looked like rays.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh!
I'm making two biscuit bases
and I've just put two bases in the water.
Mmm.
This is terrible.
I'm going to make a poison.
Oh, yeah, you like that?
Oh, my God.
Look at that.
Do you see that science happening?
God, the ring light is absolutely blinding.
Hold on.
Ring light, can you...
Can you turn it down a little bit, too?
So, you know, you can actually see
who you're going to be tonight.
Okay, that's close.
It's probably as best as I can do.
Sorry about the orange hue.
We're in Mexico right now.
Right, so that's the second one.
And then we're going to take our Kawhi Disney spoon
and we're going to just...
Oh.
Who...
How science-y.
We love a woman in STEM, truly.
This ooh, that is...
It looks like baby food, but worse somehow.
Why is it hydrophobic?
Can you see how dry that is?
Why is this hydrophobic?
Oh, it smells like a nice kind of sweet though.
Hold on a minute.
Yeah.
I'm not sure how much it gets.
Mommy trying to say,
Jesse, we need to cook.
Jesse, we're cooking.
We're popping cooking, Jesse.
Oh, my God, it's like...
I mean, we can...
You can always add water, but you can't take it out.
So let's give it a good mix before...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Cuttlefish can't follow instructions meant for a kid.
Dimo?
And I'm proud of that.
How dare you.
Thank you for your super chat cherry as well.
Yonk, mine too.
Dimo?
Sometimes you just got to go with the flow.
Life doesn't have to be so structured and rules and...
Oh, you have to do this.
You have to do that.
Sometimes it's okay to just let nature take its course.
And just because I'm low IQ,
I accept that nature is taking its course here
because what the fuck?
Oh, my God, there's so much powder in the corner.
Surely.
Right, I'm going to add a droplet of water.
Truly.
Mummy colors outside the lines.
I don't need no lines to guide me.
I just let the rotters and take over.
Bro, there were...
So Arissa messaged me
and I'm not leaking anything for Arissa's debut.
You can't stop me.
If you didn't know Arissa is my shorts editor,
she was like...
She was showing me updates on her model.
I'm not leaking it.
It's cute.
It's quite disney though.
And she was like...
I mean, I would be really nice to play together
if you want to play type thing.
And I was like...
If you want to do another collab type thing,
I'm like,
Arissa, of course I want to collab with you.
Don't be a silly Billy.
And she was like,
okay, it's just because I don't want to be so forthcoming
because of the autism and all that.
And I'm like,
Arissa, you're my favorite kind of person.
Because when both parties have autism,
you can let...
Oh, I dropped something.
I'm not putting that in.
It's like...
I'll pop it right here
so you can see it in the corner of the stream
so you can see my failures.
Okay?
It's okay to look in the past,
but don't dwell on your failures.
Okay?
There's a bit of wisdom.
You can look in the past,
but don't dwell on it.
Don't dwell on it.
Okay?
But when both parties have autism,
it's so fucking easy to communicate
because you...
There's no beating around the bush.
There's no...
Oh, hi.
And then like eight billion messages later,
you finally get the balls to say to each other,
do you want to collab?
It's like,
hi, do you want to collab?
Here's time.
Here's game.
Here's backup game.
Yes or no?
And like...
Sorry, but...
There might be some VTubers out there
who are being like,
strongy.
I don't like the way you ask that.
And look, I respect it.
Okay?
I respect it.
But me personally,
I like no dilly-dallying.
Okay, I think we've done it.
You guys okay if I finger this?
That's exactly what's about to happen.
The spoon is cute, but...
It's no way I'm mashing this.
Okay, we're making the base of the cookies,
which is this yellow here.
Okay.
Straight to the point.
No, that's not much.
Okay.
So that's what our thing looks like.
Would you like to take a bite?
As you can see,
the sugar is not mashed in.
It actually has a really nice vanilla thing to it.
I assume I'm pressing it into this.
I mean, I don't see why I wouldn't be.
Oh wait, maybe take half since I use both sashes.
And then I'm just pressing it in.
This isn't how it's supposed to be.
I'm sorry.
This is the only logic I can sense from this.
Well...
Okay, yeah.
No.
And then just take some of that.
A little bit of this and a little bit of that.
And just pat it down.
A little finger and never hurt.
Oh, you know, is this another puzzle game?
I'm starting to think it is.
I'm starting to get a bit nervous.
It's a bit shaky.
I mean, if we've got a base, that's all you need to start with.
As long as it's a flared base, you're good to go.
Let's stop it.
Stop making these jokes.
You don't have to do that every two seconds.
I know, but my brain comes up with it.
Look, I'm on three hours of sleep.
Go easy on me.
Did you see my new short?
That's totally pinned in the chat right now.
If I didn't mess it up, it should still be in.
Oh, sorry.
I was getting distracted.
Okay, we have our heading.
And we're going to eat on the plastic
because I've not got enough microplastics.
I want macroplastics, motherfucker.
I'm going to eat these packets by the end of this stream.
Okay, we have our beloved bases.
Please come.
It's like, oh my God.
I'm so talented.
What the fuck?
Oh my God.
It's an actual love heart.
I love it already.
I understand.
I can just wipe it on the tail.
Oh my God.
I can just wipe on the tail.
Okay, we've done step yellow.
Now for step red.
We're to hold on.
What are we supposed to do?
We are to put red in the top corner
and then put it on the little dots.
Curious.
Curious, but why, why of course?
Huh?
Why of course?
Is that another...
Sorry, there's bits everywhere.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
We are learning.
Microplastics are yummy.
Thank you, exactly.
What do you mean microplastics
can transfer through the umbilical cord
and cause autism when they knew this 20 years ago
but purposely hid them?
What?
Are you talking about your silly sausages?
That's a little bit too radical of a fact.
Actually, 20 years ago
was the latest published in the Epic Fingers,
probably much further back.
Wait, I can't get in.
Gelatin.
It actually has French on it.
Oh.
Well, it has a lot of lingus on it.
Hold on a minute.
Right, so the first one says
cookie dough powder in Japanese.
Don't ask me how I know that.
Oh my gosh, I have a buggy.
You want to eat my buggy?
You want to eat my buggy me?
It's the powder, really.
Um...
Hold on, please.
Cookie dough powder.
Do you want to focus again?
I'm sorry, that was so gross.
That was such a gross.
Come on.
Don't be shy.
Focus on the word.
Oh, I just punched the mic.
Let's not have that.
Go for one.
Come on, focus on the word's webcam.
Oh!
Paste o kaka?
Oh, hell no, I need this.
Right.
Okay, we're putting the red
in this little
kionail.
Little kionail.
Okay.
Oh, look at this.
Oh my God.
So Kawaii doesn't need it.
So I am to put
the red
in these little dots.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
It's not only Japanese.
Where is my little water?
Oh, I found my water.
Oh, hydration check.
Refluence.
Cheers.
Kampai.
Or cream pie.
Oh, no wait.
Cream pie.
Or kampai.
I can't remember.
It was a very long time ago.
In a far away land.
Oh, no.
I'm missing donuts and stuff.
Sorry.
I can't see it from here.
Reverse.
Thank you.
Avcron.
Thank you for the extended time.
Tiny Spiny.
Imagine being hydrophobic.
Like how can you be afraid of water?
Literally just drink it
and then it's gone.
Easy clap.
Wait until you learn what
the last stage of rabies is.
Where the kill stage of rabies is.
You're gonna shit.
I'm gonna shit your pants
when I teach you real quick
what the last stage of rabies is.
You develop hydrophobia
and once that happens,
you're done.
So you're gone.
Bill's eye.
Ain't nothing you can do.
The rabies one.
They've taken over your immune system.
It makes you think that water bad.
But really, water would.
But you can't overcome it.
Don't.
The footage is pretty rough
if you look up.
Anyway, enough about rabies.
Have it back to
Right.
It said.
Just wipe that right.
Anyway, you can't see it.
Let me just wipe that.
It's actually rather terrifying.
Oh, sweet, man.
Well, it's not man-made, actually.
Oh, yeah.
You like that.
The way I stir the spoon.
Oh, this is so sweet.
What?
I'm very curious
about what the sugar content
of any of this is.
Wait, have I put too much water in?
No, this is one.
Am I to leave the droplets?
Oh, is it gelatinous?
And it gelatinizes
or whatever the
freaking smart terminology is.
Oh, my gosh, that's so cute.
That's it.
I'm developing a game
and it's just pop and cooking,
but like a video game of it.
Because this is so cute.
What the heck?
Why do I have so much?
Oh, my God, it's like strawberry jam.
I think that's what it's supposed to be.
Oh, my gosh.
Gently.
Easy.
We have to get it right.
Right, now I did it.
Is it just...
I don't...
Well, we're to make matcha.
We'll just move on to the green step
and leave the red.
So we're to clear this out
if the best we can.
Sorry, I need to pick my nose again.
Do you guys want to eat that?
And then we're to put green in the...
now.
So we're just going to let the jellies gelify.
Are you sure I can't convince you?
I'm just saying.
Would you like a green pie?
Thank you, remember?
Okay, this is our failure.
So we're going to put our failures over there.
That's okay.
Mommy, no.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Right, next clore.
Choose your clore.
Any clore is green.
Green.
What?
Why is there a third biscuit that I don't have?
Is that where the chocolate stage is?
This is the third chocolate.
Okay, this is where the third one is.
Okay, I was so confused, right?
We're going to very quickly make the third one
because I was like, why is it not here?
I don't understand what step I've missed,
but they've not done it as a step.
They've included it in the vanilla
and this is chocolate waffle.
Okay, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Don't pun.
No pun.
Oh, he's so smart.
Only took me how long to figure it out.
Don't answer that.
Let me do that.
Let me take...
It does gelatinize.
Oh no, how do I take it out of this?
How do I...
How do I take it out of the blender?
Okay, well, it's not quite set yet, but...
Okay, this is when it starts to fall apart.
Okay, I'm going to taste it.
Are you sure you don't want to taste it first?
All right.
Well, you don't like my strawberry jam?
Angel, thank you for the super.
I just wanted to say you're super cute and thorg.
It's jaffy.
Okay, very sweet.
Very sweet.
Let me just pop that right there
for no particular reason.
Just going to wipe off the old sin.
Yeah.
It's popping out right there.
Okay, now to make our chocolate waffle.
Oh jeez.
We are making the chocolatine.
Oh my God, remember that time I taught you guys
that France is currently having a war with itself
over if it's called pan au chocolat or chocolatine?
That's right.
So if you want to be controversial...
I don't know.
I can't remember how the fight goes.
I think pan au chocolat is like...
If you want to say it like new,
but chocolatine is if you want to say it old.
But it's kind of like one of those things where it's like,
well, it's not a sausage roll.
It's a Greek sausage roll, you know?
You know, like those kind of arguments
that are just so silly and no one gets it.
Oh my God, this is got chocolate in it.
Cocoa.
Okay.
This is needing a bit of water.
Damn, the worst start here too, chocolatine.
That's right.
Even the English know about it.
The English speakers know about the French war going on.
Okay, that was far too much.
I'm making it work though.
I'm mixing it up.
What do you mean going back and forth like this isn't mixing it up?
Gonna be burning her.
Do you?
Right, okay, so this is like low key.
So you know when you watch those special videos at night
and whenever it's like not self-made,
like it's production,
how is it that the woman's DJ set,
DJ set can handle this?
How?
How is that not burning off?
Please, I must understand.
Do you have any nerves there or are they all gone?
Because how is this occurring?
How is that even possible?
Netonito, thank you for the membership upgrade.
I don't, that's a really weird way.
Thank you for the membership.
Enjoy the moment.
That's the fun part.
They don't, like that's what my question is.
Because how can you touch the DJ deck?
These are bunny ears by the way,
even though it's just the last three fingers of mine going.
How can the DJ deck be touched
and it just doesn't,
it just doesn't burn
and it doesn't feel like you want to end it all
because it's so painful.
Hmm.
Rather strange.
Oh.
Oh my god, this is so cute.
Okay, I like this part
because I don't have to do anything for it,
like it's just happening.
You know, I don't have to think about anything.
It's just life's good, okay?
Life is so quiet, isn't it?
I should have cute copyright free background music in right now.
And there's a little like bubble pop on that.
Don't forget to sell everything you own for this drone.
No, no, that's not a thing.
There is a donathon for me coming up
but you'll understand when you see my goals
what mine is all about.
But no, do not sell your worldly possessions.
Thank you, Cartofel, for the extended membership.
I see and Merci's emotes have been sent away.
Actually, they're extended.
I love it.
Ah!
It's so cute.
The Minecraft music.
Callous beans?
What, me?
Because of this?
Because of the way I write with a pencil?
Alright, did I misunderstand?
Four foot on mortal possessions the moment?
No.
No, I've had my rage fit.
Right, if you guys want, do you guys want some secret
YouTube membership stream links?
Grembo understood we mortgage them all for this?
No.
I screamed at the refunds yesterday for the first time
in a membership stream.
And you know how much I love my refunds
but they would not stop giving me money for nothing.
Like, nothing in return.
And I was like,
Okay guys, stop it now.
Okay guys, guys, you can stop it now.
Guys.
Guys, you can stop.
Stop it, really.
Stop it.
And then I kept going.
And then literally I was like, fucking knock it off.
I can't remember what words I said.
It was probably harsher, like, in my head than it was that
what came out.
But I was like, save your money.
Save your dang money.
Like, stop giving me your money.
Wait until the donathon.
Jeez.
I still have a Bruce Tentacle mummy thing.
We shouldn't leak the membership discussion there,
she does it.
That's hardly leaking what was inside the donathon goals.
I felt like, yeah, I started screaming at the refunds
because it wouldn't stop giving me money.
Okay, green stage.
This is two.
Okay, wait, is our jelly ready now?
Oh.
Oh, it's so cute.
It's so cute.
The donathon.
Hello, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm not the person.
What the fuck?
I'm a govish.
Okay, we both have tentacles.
I know.
Oh my God, this is so cute.
Oh my God, it's so slippery.
Like, it's so slippery.
Like, oh, it's so nice and slippery.
Rudolph, right now it's reindeer.
Had a very shiny nose.
And if you ever saw it, you would even see it close.
And all the other reindeer used to laugh and call him names.
Perle, old Rudolph.
Goes down in history.
I can't remember the rest of it.
Oh my gosh, this, I love it.
More.
More, more, more, more, more.
I also believe, more.
Okay, and then the one that I kinda demolished because I couldn't figure out like a big,
like a big ogre on how to get out.
This is so cute.
Will you guide my sleight of mind?
Can you tell?
Oh.
Huh.
Fuck that one up, Chief.
It's already gelatinised in the-
What is gelatinised in the corner?
Mm-hmm.
Well, that was definitely an IQ test part that I failed.
But hey ho, we now have a beautiful rectangle of jelly.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, right, enough throwing the powder around.
What does this green stuff-
It says use two water on the green stuff.
And then we can just use like dots and stuff on the green stuff and make what we want.
They make it a lot more kawaii disune on the front.
I mean, like what you got advertised to versus what you receive.
We'll do that after.
Yeah, go let them know you's good story.
Uh, crazy Jessie and we'll do it again.
Thank you for the super chat.
At least keep your money for the doughnathon so I can have exciting things prepared.
Now if you want to hear about what kind of preparations I've got in place so I can steamroll my goals.
And the girls can attest to this because they have access to the schedule.
I have planned all my streams all the way up to October 12th, which is after the doughnathon.
And the girls can attest to this because they can see it on the schedule.
And I need to add all the membership streams on top.
But I am making sure that I deliver all of the goals like as soon as possible.
Like as soon as I can muster.
What the fuck?
It asks for two water.
Okay, as you are my witness that says two water.
I guess this is just gelatinous one.
It's the difference between jelly and jam is that I can't jelly my tentacle into your clam.
You're done.
I thought you were actually telling me a fact about the difference between them.
I was going to be like oh that's so cute.
Okay I forgot to clean it so there's a bit of caca just making its way around please.
No.
Oh that stinks.
What is that supposed to be?
Can you smell it and tell me what flavour is that?
Oh it's fake watermelon.
I love that watermelon.
Okay we're mixing the watermelon.
And then.
Chloric acid.
Yeah pretty much.
Thank you the beauty lord for the super chat.
Oh a reflin sent me a message.
I'm so sorry.
A reflin was, I'm so sorry if this is you.
You sent me a super chat or something.
You sent me money and I forgot to say your name twice in a row apparently.
I was very overwhelmed in the member stream.
I do apologise.
I promise I'm not like some nasty hideous ogre.
I was very overwhelmed with all the donations and stuff.
What the fuck is that consistency?
Is that your ink when you've had too much zinc?
It like, oh this is like, can you hear that?
That's audibly going, that's audibly sponsored by no one.
Okay.
Well it was gonna happen.
Right so the picture has got one half of this waffle green.
So Imma just copy what it does.
Oh my gosh.
It's, oh look at me.
I'm putting acid in.
I really am the chef and you take the onion and you pat it down on the waffle.
Yeses.
And what are they done?
They've done like dots around it as well, around the perimeter.
Right we'll do dots around the perimeter like this one.
I don't know how easy it is to see.
Do you have my full screen or am I on a phone for you?
How big am I to you right now?
Am I full screen?
Be honest.
You're inking on my cookie, inking on my cookies like you wanted me.
Honestly all the time.
Okay dot, dot, oh dot, dot.
That's not happening.
It's getting rather gelatinous fast.
Please, please stop reacting so quickly.
I don't have to, we're on a timer.
Okay dot, dot, and a dot on the bottom.
Okay, all done.
That was the green.
We have lots of green left over.
And then we have last and certainly not least purple,
which were to put in the cheese slice bag,
one water of purple, put it in the bag and then cut the corner of the bag.
And then there's a square of jelly.
Oh, the jelly is supposed to become a rectangle.
Okay, we're to put it in the cheese slice.
I do love me a cheese slice.
Are these edible?
Do you want me to put it in my mouth?
I could put it in my mouth.
I can't promise I'm going to swallow, but I could put it in.
I would be rather nervous too.
Okay, right, cheese slice as you are my witness, cheese slice.
I'm just listening at work.
Okay, rather powdery.
A bit more, bit more.
Spitters or quivers.
It's edible, sure.
If it's not edible, no, let's not.
Okay, we need one more.
Okay.
It says to mix it in the pot, but what's the point in doing that?
I'm just going to mix it in the bag.
Okay, easy.
We've got a one-handed operation going, okay?
Like, you say you watch my streams one-handed all the time.
Ooh, why did that wobble like that?
You're making me nervous.
Are these edible in the first place?
Yes, they're supposed to be...
Pop and Cookin' is supposed to be edible sweets that you, like, finish making.
It's supposed to be, like, a wee thing for wanes, I think.
I mean, I do have the brain like you have a wane.
Okay, so we just put it in the bag.
And then we just swirl it around.
It's specifically said to, like...
I don't know, I was just going to shake it up like that.
Well...
Why does this look like SPH same?
No, it kind of does, though.
But I'm shuggling it up. I'm shuggling and wiggling.
Look, I'm squeezing, I'm squeezing.
Pop and Cookin'.
What kind of shake is that?
Well, I don't know what it, like, violently is.
Like, you could shake it like this, I guess.
Oh, we can give it inertia.
Okay, let's do it. Let's give it some G-force.
G-force. Oh, yeah.
Give it some science, baby.
Hit him with the physics.
Okay, are you mixed up now?
It looks like a...
I just...
POV, you hire me to pinch and roll for you.
There you go. Is that better?
Yeah, it's the itching stops.
Give it a little pinch and roll, yeah.
Okay, a little pinch and roll.
There you go. There you go.
A little cheeky pinch and roll.
Yeah, that'll do it.
That'll do it, Bunky, a little bit.
Congrats on 23,000 subscribers.
Did I actually hit that milestone?
As normally, I am nervous hitting a milestone,
but I have so much ASMR coming out, I'm not nervous.
I'm like, bring it on, motherfucker.
Thank you so much, everyone.
Thank you, Reflings.
The milking farm is going to get rather large.
I did not anticipate so many weekends.
Right, let's cut the corner
faster than later.
Okay, so they've done, like, purple dots and hearts.
They've put the purple in between the waffle
thingy-ma-bob.
Okay, I can do that.
I'm going to remove our little jelly hearts
and then I'm going to roll this.
Oh, wait, how did they do it on the back?
They said tie a knot on it.
Nah, I can't be harsh, but thanks.
You take them in and you take the sun.
I'm so sorry, I don't know what sun that is.
I thought we were singing Christmas carols.
Right, this is...
Oh, that was rather a large incision.
Okay, we just need to very gently...
Thank you, the tongue...
Super chill.
Oh!
Skills.
I'm a surgeon.
I am a surgeon.
Now, the heart didn't really perfect itself
at the top and the bottom, so I can't really...
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
Oh, there's a little extra leakage,
but that's perfectly normal, please don't...
Okay, and then...
What, they did love hearts on the green here?
How do you draw?
That's too intricate to draw a love heart.
It's just a dot.
Hi Jane, I tried to draw a love heart.
That's just a dot.
Hold on, can I just move you at the bottom there?
Okay, that's good, just a little tap there.
Thank you, Athenae, for the extended membership.
Justine, hi, while I'm studying, it looks tasty.
You'd eat the...
Do you want to die?
Do you want to meet your maker?
What?
How did they make a love heart?
Did they use the spoon?
Maybe.
I will design a love heart.
Oh, we've got a bit of shapeage going on.
Hold on a minute, don't write me out just yet.
Put me back in, coach.
Put me back in, and then if I artificially extend the top part up here...
Oh, that's a triangle.
That's what that is, love.
That's a triangle.
Okay, I've made a triangle.
There you go.
It's a freaking triangle.
I'm just wanting the cute little love heart.
Love heart, geez.
Fine, you're getting dots on the rest of...
Oh, that's not even a dot.
Please, dot.
Dot.
And then the finishing touches.
That's a triangle.
Yeah, triangle.
Hydration check.
Draw a tentacle.
Why would I draw one when I'm already repping the merch?
That's right.
Strony at Oogoo Market.
Or if you prefer my gen mates, they also get 100% as well,
because we all don't take a cut like that.
Oh, actually, I got...
Where's the sprinkles?
Oh, the sprinkles is just on it.
I got a marshmallow and it was like,
I bet you're so mad that you don't take a fansly cut.
And I'm like, motherfucker, you know,
we have terrible news for you.
We never specified it.
I don't expect the girls to do it.
I don't expect any future girls to do it.
Of course, they can reap 100% of the...
Oh my gosh, there's a love heart in here.
And it's green reeflings.
It's literally us.
Oh, shh.
You didn't see me throw the sprinkles everywhere.
It's literally us because it's green.
It's so cute.
Do I taste it?
Do I smell it?
Mmm, smells mass produced.
I might just sprinkle all this shit everywhere.
Oh, yeah.
And then the last finishing touches.
Boop.
And...
Now, reeflings.
I'm going to put it on our triangle heart
because that's where it belongs.
Reeflings, I'm going to ask you to close your eyes
temporarily, okay?
I try to close your eyes.
I wish there was a close-eyes emote,
but I don't really have that.
Okay, so you have been advertised
to come to the new Veiler exclusive cafe.
Oh, let me get the cooking instructions out of the way.
You've been...
Oh, we got raided.
Thank you so much.
Hi, raiders.
I'm so sorry.
The freaking notifications are so broken.
It didn't even pop up saying I was raided.
Thank you so much for raiding.
Who did it?
Own up to it.
Own up to who raided me right now.
Own up.
Oh, I just realized that I have a five-minute subscriber-only modon.
I have...
It was Kendra.
Thank you, Kendra, for the raid.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Hi, I'm Strawny.
I'm wildly inappropriate from Veiler.
You'll probably prefer my gen mates.
Check them out in the description below.
We're currently doing pop and cooking.
So you've entered the Veiler cafe.
You've ordered off the menu three waffles,
one chocolate, two vanilla.
It looks delicious.
All you hear in the background is pots and pans banging.
I'm swearing in Scottish.
Amy's popping off in Canadian.
Merci.
She's spitting a bit of Vietnamese.
I don't know what's going on.
She's just having a good time back there.
Shibi and Azura are bickering over something.
And Aisy with her paws can hardly pick anything up.
So that's what's going on in the background.
And you think to yourself,
I'm sure this is going to be fine.
Surely.
They've got this cracked down.
It's just three basic waffles.
And then you hear the door open.
The music starts playing.
And you hear all six of us in unison.
Ah, master.
Your waffles are ready.
Okay.
And then we say, master,
please close your eyes for the reveal of the delicious food.
Master.
And then you close your eyes,
which you're doing now.
Your eyes are closed.
And then you open your eyes
to the delicious plate.
Oh, my God.
That is foul.
And you think to yourself,
open the cafe.
You think to yourself,
damn, these girls really are a girl feel.
Yeah.
And then,
and then as we walk away back into the kitchen,
Squidward walking sound effects and all,
you quickly grab the menu
just to revise over what you ordered.
And you say to yourself,
no, I'm not going crazy.
And then you check.
Oh.
That is disgusting.
Anyway.
And that's why they were arguing in the back.
Yes.
We were arguing if we should serve it to you or not,
but we ended up serving it to you.
It's an actual war crime.
No.
I'll eat it.
You're not going to make it out on the other side if you eat this.
Thanks for the water.
What?
Thanks for the waffle.
It looks even better than advertised.
That is concrete.
That is,
that is one schemas.
And how much,
so we paid $9.95 to get it into the cafe.
Do you know how much we upcharged you?
$15 for this.
You've been upcharged $5.05.
How does it make you feel?
Does it make you want to correct us?
Oh, dear.
Oh, no.
You should totally not correct the valour girls.
Well, hey.
Oh, no.
What a punishment.
Thank you to Tonethay for the super chat.
Oh, yeah.
The brat cafe?
I mean, I will order as a maid outfits right now.
I'll get everyone to do one pop and cooking stream.
And then,
okay, I'm going to put it in my mouth.
Eenie meenie meenie mo.
Catch the tiger by the toe.
If it squeals, let it go.
Eenie meenie meenie mo.
Okay.
We're doing it.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Right.
To continue the story,
you ask,
you ask strongy to come over to the,
your table and you say,
excuse me strongy,
this isn't quite advertised.
Are you sure it's edible?
And I say to you,
of course it's edible.
Don't be silly.
You don't trust me.
Look,
I'll eat it right in front of you, master.
I'm so scared to bite into this.
But you see the nervous look on my face,
knowing full well this is not edible
in any degree.
Did I put the whole thing in my mouth?
Hmm.
Yeah, why not?
What are you talking about?
It's completely edible.
Here, have a bite.
Here's your,
your half eaten waffle back to you,
covered in my spit.
Oh, hold on.
That's why having a towel down is the best thing.
You just spit right on the towel.
That is veil.
Don't recommend.
Nope.
And it's still stuck on my lips.
Oh, it's making me salivate,
but not the good kind.
Hold on.
Let me,
let me just,
bleh.
My spit is literally tainted pink.
That's how much like,
like sugary stuff and all that.
It's that bad.
The reaction was so quick.
That was terrifying.
Anyway,
I hand you back your ordered waffles.
Here you go, master.
Please enjoy.
And thank you for paying
before seeing the product.
I place it down on the table
and walk away in embarrassment.
And let's just say you were the last customer
at the cafe before it shut down.
That is,
that is my vealer cafe opening story.
It looks like mush.
Yes.
I mean,
everything is like,
it's like all good fun.
What do you mean you don't want the
heat up,
reefing,
here master,
enjoy.
Wait,
what do you mean you don't trust my cooking?
Look at the spoon.
I cooked this myself.
You did better than Emmy.
Emmys didn't go that badly, did it?
But that's their ink.
Okay.
I won't make you eat your ink.
Only in a later audio.
Look,
no, I don't care.
I don't care if you think it's weird.
I like it.
Whoa,
it's so perfectly round.
I want to play with it.
Oh,
the corners are round.
See,
look,
we did make it in-house.
You thought we ordered this product
and it was,
it wasn't,
like,
stored well?
Oh,
that's so satisfying to touch.
I could play with this
for a little while.
Yeah,
I like that.
yeah,
you do,
you like that shit,
don't you?
What do you mean master,
you're going to report us?
No,
no,
don't do that.
Shh,
don't do that,
master.
Fond de la Gelo,
oh,
no,
that's even worse.
If
Azura ever gets drawn as a slime,
whoever commissions that,
call it Fond de la Gelo.
That's all I'm saying.
This cafe is not OSHA certified.
Wait,
use it for ASMR.
I'm not putting this
on my microphone.
See,
that's a wrong,
this side,
satisfaction,
look at the corners.
How could you go around?
That's so good.
You can see how
wet it's making my hands.
Mm,
but you see,
like all the glue,
but,
you don't like my hat,
you don't like...
Eek!
That's what I think about you
popping,
cooking.
Oh,
that does not feel nice
when it's like this though.
Mm.
Oh my God,
it's making
really squelchy noises.
Look,
all I'm saying is,
if you have pop and cooking at home
and you don't want to eat it,
you can 100%
just
make some ASMR with it.
Uh,
oh wait,
I keep forgetting,
I literally put a towel
to do this.
That's,
that's literally why
I brought a towel through.
So I can just do this,
and I don't have to like,
baller about cleaning my hands
every two seconds.
Look,
see,
we can literally do it together.
Mm.
Did you know that
when you wash your hands,
do you want to know
what the most forgotten part
of your hand is?
When you wash it,
it's this section.
Yeah.
When you wash your hands,
this is the most forgotten section
that harbours the bacteria
because everyone
forgores.
And uh,
yeah.
Also got some kitchen roll.
It's Johnny a dirty girl.
All right,
my fourth year.
What?
It's ketchup season yet?
No, it's not.
Fingernail.
Wrist.
No, don't look at my wrist.
Look at the wrist.
Hey,
never look in that part again.
I mean, we did it.
No,
we do have another one.
I'm not doing it
because
that was just too much.
I did not expect any of that.
That was too hard.
So I'm just going to ramble.
Is she becoming on?
Oh my God.
Oh, I didn't even realize
it's not even being an MRG.
Damn.
Really short stream for me.
I don't think I've ever had
such a short.
Oh, no, I have Lego Lord of the Rings
part three
because,
well, yeah.
Oh God,
the second cooking set.
No, I need to clean.
So basically what I need to do,
I need to clean all this up
and put it in the washing machine
and put,
like,
in the,
we will,
I'll give it to the birds, okay?
The birds will eat.
I'm not even feeding that
to the birds.
No, sure.
I ain't feeding them poison.
I'm more than happy
to just look at you ramble.
Not the bee.
We're blanks.
Huh?
You're going to torture them?
No, no.
I fed the birds
a cheese and ham quathons.
This sounds really dumb,
but I forgot how buttery
quathons are.
You know how quathons
are known for
being really buttery
and flaky
and baked in a buttery,
flaky crust?
So there's a second
poppin' kick in.
Don't,
that's terrible.
Don't underlive those magpies.
Never cook again.
This was not it.
Quathons are like 90% butter.
Literally,
so I don't mind butter,
but I don't exactly love it.
Have a memory of my gran
feeding me
supper
and supper
was just bread and butter,
alright?
But the butter was so caked on
that when I took a bite,
you could see my teeth
in dense in the butter
and that is my,
whenever I think of butter,
that's all I think about.
And I remember forcing myself
to eat it
and trying not to like upset her
because she'd made me
my supper,
like because I was having
a sleepover with her
and that's all I remember.
That's all I think about
with butter.
It was so buttery
that my teeth marks
were left in the butter.
That's how much butter
was on that bread.
Classic British supper,
literally
a bit of salt
on the bread.
Butter and a bit of salt
and that was supper.
That was supper to keep me
going until morning
after my sleepover
with my gran.
The French will remember
that stuff.
Stop, you made me
drop my croissant.
I don't have anything
interesting to show you
other than that though.
I'm afraid this is like,
I ain't that
interesting of a person.
I ain't got anything to show.
Unless you want me to
roll play with the key chains,
I can do that.
Wherever they are,
they are in this room.
Or I can do a little
dance for you.
Okay, no, seriously,
where are the key chains?
Oh, there they are.
I found them.
They're under all my
ASMR stuff.
Okay.
We do
a little bit of chilling
and then
I'll wrap it up
as a short stream
just because I have had
three original
hours of sleep.
And I'm not wet.
It's shielded.
So I'm going to make
an ASMR video soon to you.
I actually
maybe could do it
within this week.
Let's not put them
on the sticky.
Let's be a bit nicer
to my gen mates.
Okay, they worked a little
too hard to be put on
sticky towels
from our maid cafe
experience.
Doesn't look.
So what I'm going to do
is just like a basic
ASMR.
I'm going to have my fake nails
on.
Actually, I have a different
fake nails set on
for when I record this video.
Let me grab it for you.
So this...
Oh, that's absolutely
there's nothing in there.
Hold on.
This is it.
Oh, and this is the
shock collar
that wants my
my phone number
to activate.
I offered the girls
it for free if they wanted
it.
But no one took me up
on the offer.
And they were probably like
strong.
He's fucking crazy
because I was like,
hey girls,
it takes your tracking data
and your phone number
and your location
and most likely opens up
like your phone book
and grabs all your contacts.
But you can have it
if you want it.
And no one took me up
on that offer.
But they're probably like
strong.
He's fucking mental.
And it's like, you know what?
Maybe I'm maybe I'm
but yeah,
this is the nail set.
This is the other nail set
I got.
Look.
Oh my God.
There's no way.
Hey, hey, hey.
But I was going to wear
these fake nails
and then I was going to
tap all the girls' faces.
I really like
this brand.
No, I know.
Hold on.
I know audience's mail.
All I'm saying.
Narcissist Nails.
Nails Assist.
Good brand.
I thoroughly enjoy them.
I'm probably going to buy
more stuff off their website.
I'm not even kidding.
I thoroughly,
thoroughly 10 out of 10
experience.
But we've got mercy
and then we're going to
touch mercy and tap.
So it's basically tapping
ASMR as the video
that I'm going to record.
I'm going to be recording
and literally I'm just
going to tap over.
There's going to be no talking
because I don't really see
why I would talk through this.
Oh, my voice is going out.
I've not had enough rest.
But mercy on the nose.
But yeah,
Kohai is back.
And then we've got sheeps.
Now she's the wrong color.
And I've white washed her.
Oh, dear.
Whoopsies.
Her merchandise is the wrong color.
And then we've got
Aysical.
The sleepy head.
This is actually her toggle as well.
Oops, sorry.
I just bumped him.
I could hear that.
Her toggle has little snowflakes
and bubble pops,
but she's sleepy.
She got insomnia.
She's got insomnia.
And that's a little Aysical.
And the person who made the,
how you call them,
the artworks were really good
because I was like,
at the time I was like,
please do the pupils correct.
We don't have normal pupils.
Do not send me back artwork
with normal pupils
because every time I sent away
an artwork of the girls,
they would send me pupils normal.
And I'm like,
please look at the reference sheet I have.
None of us have normal pupils.
Do not send me a fucking dot back.
I am sick of it.
Amy, she came out so mischievous.
Like, literally so, so mischievous.
Like, come on.
Look at the intention on her face.
Look at it.
Would you just look at it?
I'm so proud of you.
But yeah, they aced her design.
There's actually some hidden lore
about her book.
You know how Amy updated her design a little bit?
The book originally has a face on it
to show how evil the book was,
but it got taken out at some point during the lore
and then we ended up taking it out in the design.
But we've added it back in thanks to Amy's abilities
to fucking edit the,
the thingy mobile.
The smug aura of this keychain
is mocking me.
And then there's a sort of just pure
literally, it's just so good.
Sorry.
Sorry to be, we, sorry for unity.
Sorry, I can't help it.
Love, love me a bit of unity.
Love me a bit of unity.
Oh my god, there she is.
Look at her.
So yeah, if you see me in public with six keychains,
click clackin'.
Literally, if this is all you hear outside,
and you see all of this,
and this is on the end of a key,
yeah, it's me.
Okay, I don't care.
I'm proud.
I'm sorry, I do.
I'm biased.
I don't care what you,
I don't care what you say.
But that's me.
I have to admit,
Chibi's work so well with my design.
Like, Chibi's work fantastically well with my design.
Sorry, I said it, I'm biased.
I'm biased.
But look how adorable I am.
Please focus.
Focus.
You better focus on me.
You know what?
I'm doing the influencer hand thing.
So yeah, there we go.
I forced the focus.
I just, sorry.
Chibi is just so complimentary.
What is unity?
Unity is a terminology for when,
it could be a gen.
Maybe it's a full agency.
You guys might know better than me.
Unity means that I like fully give my all
in terms of like, I love everyone equally.
And I don't know,
you guys would define it better than me.
It just means I love all my girls.
To me, that's what unity means.
I love them.
But you guys probably have a better definition.
Unity, it's a game development.
Reflang, no.
Unity, well, you're not wrong.
But unity means like, I love all my gen mates
and surely that's what it means.
I mean, you love your girls equally with no favoritism.
Fuck yeah, I demand unity.
I demand it.
I demand unity.
I kneel.
I can't kneel any harder.
I'm demanding so much unity right now.
At least even more cut offish like a Chibi
because of the bigger head.
So, I mean, you can kind of see the hidden design elements.
I think I've spoken about my design before.
The hidden element is my hair comes out
like the side of a cephalopod.
My bangs as well also do that.
You see the out-of-sidey pointy bits of my hair.
That's to mimic a cephalopod.
And then the bottom of my feet as well.
Obviously you won't be able to see it in the Chibi design.
But the bottom of my feet are the body shape
of a cephalopod as well.
And then my yukata is a homage to Japanese culture
because would we be here without it?
Made up a definition.
How dare you?
I remember being more insulted in my life.
Show us with your model.
I mean...
We're gonna...
The tracking is gonna get lost
because the tracking's on the floor, okay?
Oh, I did not mean that.
Oh no.
Oh no, you can see my heart.
You can see my soul.
I remember learning that Americans
apparently get bullied for washing their clothes.
You see the design of the tape around my legs?
That's the cephalopod.
And then that's my eyes.
And then that's me.
You're dead.
Nothing.
Nothing?
Wait, sorry, the tracking is on the floor right now.
I had to basically move all of my setup from desk
as you see my hands in the shadows from desk
to floor.
Not easy.
No, no, not quick.
That's why it took me so long to pop up.
I didn't even have time to be like,
oh my god, give me a minute.
I was like...
Like, there's currently...
You're sitting on a tripod.
The microphone is in the air.
You know, that I can do that with.
The lighting source, my ring light and my tracking
is over here.
And then you know, I had to set this up.
I had to put it all there.
I mean, I literally went and ran and got bowls
because I was like, I think I need a...
Oh, you can see Gimli's cat here in the bowl.
I was like, I think I need a bowl for this stream.
I don't know why.
Maybe I need a bowl to mix stuff up in.
It was not good.
I was like, oh look, it's my hair.
It's getting longer.
Don't worry, my hair grew back after cutting it
for Mercy.
It comes back, I promise.
But yes, so this was very hard,
but I'm going to do a membership ASMR
and real life camera thing in my bobber.
Not my face or my body.
I'm literally going to take all this away
and clean it up.
And then I'm going to put the 3Dial here
and then you can watch me as I actually do.
But yeah!
That's it, I don't have anything else
exciting to show, I'm afraid.
I'm probably going to be
ballsy and contact
a company in Japan
that specializes in unique figurines
for the girls.
I'm going to see if they're willing to work with us.
Because I think,
I think now that we've all surpassed
10k subscribers
that they
would be willing.
But I need to see what the...
I don't want the girls to be wasting their time
promoting something
if they're not getting a good cut.
If that means I have to forego my cut
then, you know, so be it.
Did you show your schedule?
Oh no I didn't!
Hold on, let me get my schedule.
Don't look at my feet.
What, what do you mean?
Don't look at my feet, make sure I'm holding it.
Oh no.
Oh no, my ankle.
Oh, my ankle.
Oh no.
Okay, hold on, let me start,
let me show my schedule.
Shimmy shimmy shimmy shimmy shimmy
yaha
wa da da da
Hold on, I'm getting my schedule.
I'm getting my schedule.
I had to cover up the artwork.
Now, before I know
get the point is, one relax.
So, I'm trying my best, okay?
There we go.
Okay, I'm going to cover up my face
because my tracking is going to be off
because I'm up here.
But we're going to see if we can
100% complete
Sonic Heroes
And then we're going to finish
all of Vermintay 2 stream sniping
I'm purposely doing on
a week day for the stream snip
because I don't want anyone
who worked weekends to completely miss out
So, we're going to finish all of Vermintay
We're going to play a game called Tavern Master
It looks like
a game that I can pretend
that we're in Hobbiton
and we're trying to run a tavern
just outside of Bree
So, I'm going to be role playing
I don't care, I love it
I'm going to give it a shot
It looks cute
And then we're going to do
a member script right in stream
which is really just me
disguising my work as content
So, yeah
If you want to watch me work
and come up with a script
We're playing the Black Ops 1 campaign
Fantastic
Juicy
Lekker
Lekkerding
Very Lekkerding
It's a gorgeous game
I think it's about a 7 to 8 hour campaign
It is quite a big campaign
especially for an older Call of Duty
Then
we're going to finalise Peggle as well
I think we've got about half way through it
So, there's probably only 2 hours to go on Peggle
And then we're going to do
Members Ballotro
I just want to chill out
and I'm testing the waters
with Members
the gaming content
Like, I've done Ballotro a lot
and I've not played it
since the last time I played it on stream
and we're going to test it
If it's good, it's good
If it's bad, it's bad
But, you know, thank you as always
for letting me experience
for the first time
Golfit is the collab
We are going to be streaming it
but we're all going to redirect into Zura
on Saturday because it has
her 12 hour donathon
There will be
graphics released very, very soon
Mommy's going to lose the house
to get washroom with Gambo
You can Peggle me any day
I am going to stream after
the Golfit collab
It's probably like an hour and a half
just because Zura's got a lot of things planned on that day
So it's not like a big major 2 hour
an hour and a half, maybe even shorter
Just so Zura can focus on
what she needs to do for her donathon
because she's going to be streaming for 12 hours
which is insane
Once the collab finishes
I've said roughly 2 hours later
At my regular time
I'm going to doodle my gen mates
but if you guys can be quiet
I'm actually secretly drawing a Zura
But don't tell her that
I'm secretly drawing a Zura
but she's not going to know
because she's not going to have time to watch the stream
so we're going to draw her together
I'm going to take a picture
of myself as a reference
I will show you it
I'm not going to show my face or anything like that
Relax, relax
But I'm going to do a pose of a Zura
in a giant test situation
and we're going to try our best
to draw it
whether or not we actually manage
the whole other thing
but we're going to try
Hi, Zura
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Hardy, hardy, hardy
You're going to water them
and then we are doing
a
redirect
ASMR
Kind of train, kind of not
Some of us are doing ASMR on that day
I am going to be early
by two hours
Two hours
I'm going to be early by two hours
on the Golf Fit collab
and on the ASMR stream
These are two hours of my usual time
but I promise I'm not changing slots
or anything like that
It was just how the timing worked out
Don't
think anymore
Why does Tavern Master say
it starts at 2 am? It doesn't
Tavern Master does not start at 2 am
Why would it start at 2 am?
I don't know why it says that
No, only the weekend
Golf Fit, a Zura
and the gang, 2 am
It's 2 am for me, not for you
and then it's 2 am for me
for the ASMR stream as well
Ah, I forget, temporary time
Stop it
You're all getting spanked
I'm not getting any of that
But yes, I think
So I am going to
Whenever
Excuse me, that was a
That was a cola burp
That wasn't this
That wasn't the
The waffle burp I've run
But yes
Excuse me for sleeping on the job
When I do
a live stream
hypnosis thing
I am going to
repurpose the script and change it up
to make into a hypnosis video
in general
Whenever you see
why do you keep making live
ASMR streams
that are hypnosis themed
You are getting the video as well
on top
Don't think
I just need to change some stuff up
to make it more better for a video
and there's going to be a lot more
visual things going to go on
I hope for the video
I'll see how it works out in the end
But it was a very weak burp
It was, thank you for rating it
though, however
But yes, it's a very casual
and familiar tavern master
I'm looking forward to it because I've never played it before
but I think everything else I actually have played
We're kind of doing a finish in everything upstream
Like I said, we've got
Sonic Heroes
We've already done that before
We've done that before but we're finishing it off
That's a stream snipe if you want a stream snipe
Don't buy the game just a stream snipe
It's not that kind of game
Let me be clear, it's not the kind of game you buy
just a stream snipe
Don't
buy the game just a stream snipe
Thank you
Putting the hip in hypnosis
I really like the hypnosis stream
Well, I'm going for it again
The plot for the hypnosis stream
is to try and forget your name
I'm going to replace it with refling
It's going to be temporary, there is going to be a temporary effect
just warning you now if that's not for you
I will have big old warnings at the top
I've not got my glasses on
and your name is blurring together
Is that say
Kamni Rob
or
Ke Ani?
Thank you for becoming a member
I don't have my glasses on
and you're rather far away
Oh wait, I can literally
You know what?
Sometimes I'm so low IQ I forget how to move
I'm allowed to move
Thank you for the membership
I'm not stuck here, I'm not glued to the ground
Relax
You can move
He said it, it wasn't me
It was him, it wasn't me
Look, it was me
But yes, I
Unfortunately
got terrible sleep
But there is fun things cooking
and brewing
But
I hope to have a big ASMR update
for you soon
I'm afraid
that I don't have got anything else
interesting
Bermontide II Collector's Edition is $4
right now
Oh
Well, when you put it like that
Maybe you can stream snipe me
No, do it for free games
We'll pick free games
I've got Left 4 Dead 2 on the roster
Coming up for a stream snipe
I'll get people in and out
I don't know how Left 4 Dead 2 works
But I assume it's going to be fine
As for other stream snipe games
I'll need to take suggestions
Um
But yeah
Anything on the corn side of
I mean
Other than regular Patreon
or like milestone rewards
Yeah
Always
Um
It's a fun game even solo
Just wish, yeah, I'm actually going to solo
Chain together
I was having so much fun playing that
It was so satisfying
I found it rather satisfying
And I liked how nice the dev team wants
to be like load your highest last save
And I'm like, yes, please
Wait until you get punched off
a building by a tank
Um
I'm looking forward to Bermontide
Tavern Golf in the ASMR Yapping
No, so
I don't have a membership ASMR
this week
But it's not because of anything
bad or like that
It's just Taemin, like the ASMR I'm about to do
I'm literally going to try hard
because I feel like I've been disappointed
in the reclines of that being like
Oh, this is ASMR and like, yeah, it's funny
that it turns into Yapping like every 2 seconds
but I feel like I'm genuinely disappointed in some people
so
Sorry
So I'm actually going to try hard once I
set up the memberships
The monthly if I try I get to try
do one thing
But yes, okay
So for the agendination
I am going to clean up
all this mess and then I'm going to
put up a membership stream
for ASMR
You'll see the microphone on the floor and I'll be fingering it
Oh, sorry
I'm going to be tingling it
That's what I meant to say, good save
I'm tingling it
I'm tingling the microphone, okay
If you just give me
about
5 minutes to clean all this up
Surely
I can't touch the webcam because it's on a tripod
and the tripod isn't stable but
there is a lot more mess than
what's going on
The first one better, one try hard ASMR for every 3 ASMR Yaps
Yeah, basically
I think I'm starting
to, you know, disappoint
a few people
Sorry for being a Yapper
Sorry for having the inability
to shut up
But that's just me
Oh my god, I can tickle my model
tickle, tickle, tickle
Wait, I can touch my head
Bunk
That's so cool
Man, I love techno
Man, I love pilot in America
I don't care why anyone says I love pilot in America
Right, enough
stalling, I'm going to redirect
into Sheber's, Sheber Tins
I know
she's not up just yet
but as a forgiveness, I'll let you look at my face
There you go
Now you forgive me so much
Oh wait, I can see bad people
Can I see bad people?
Oh, you can see my tentacle
Oh my god, you can see my tentacle
You're embarrassing me so much
Thank you so much
Anonymous
for becoming a member
You just don't gonna hurt
I bought something not on model right now
I'm sure
We love yapping
and weaponized autism
It is rather weaponized
I have to admit, I'm sorry but
I'm literally
if you didn't know
thanks for the stream, thank you SaltyZero
for the Super Chat
If you guys don't know
let me just
crouch back down, just to have a serious
one on one conversation with you
about how weaponized my specific autism is
I'm about to
hit a three month streaming streak
which is pretty insane
because it doesn't really
feel like effort in terms of like
yeah, I'm tired
and I don't get much sleep
but in terms of effort
no
there's no effort
alright, that's how weaponized
we are, we're about to hit a three month stream
and we didn't even
like, I don't think I'm walking up
once I've been like
I can't believe it
no, we're just
just a little
a little
you are so much
it's crazy keep it up, yeah
I'm finalizing a lot of
ASMR collabs
by the end of this month
because either
the girl, a few girls have agreed
to collab with me but I've left them hanging
with a script which is naughty of me
that's not very nice, I've not been updating them
which is why we're doing that
membership script during stream
and
there's going to be regular
ASMR milestone updates
and then I'm going to pursue my meme
and hypnosis stuff
as well on top
she twerks hard
but works harder, I wish I could
just straight
well, I do have a gift of it
Kendra, thank you for coming
remember
the Bratton Fair
did she show the schedule? I did
so I'm going to put them up after the ASMR stream
the ASMR stream is going to be like 2 hours
sorry, there's like still sugar on my hands
I don't know if you can tell
go stop yapping
go clean, okay okay clean
it's almost like you'd be perfect
in one of those VTuber ASMR company
man, wouldn't it be mental if I was
in like a VTuber company that specified
an ASMR
and then I never do ASMR
even though
I'm kind of like
what if all of us do ASMR
I guess it doesn't solely rest on me to be the ASMR
oh yeah
insert strong among us
twerking
can the cleaning sound
so good? a bit of stucco
I do love the stucco
right, I'm going to
I believe Shimi is next
let me just
for once in my life
let me
nodding out
I don't know what that song is
but once in my life
let me lure it
sorry, you're getting an impromptu
carryo tissue stucco on my head
for once in my life
let me
what?
what is that song?
I'm gonna pass out from my medicines.
God damn, does the Waffles kill you?
Oh, Sheeby's waiting when I'm going up.
Man, that...
She's not screaming the day then.
Nah, she's not, so what?
Eh, who would be next?
I mean, the zoo would be next.
In the stream capital, or...
But I think she's doing a membership today.
For once in my life, let me...
Okay, I think it's Azura.
It's Azura, that's right.
You're gonna redirect it into Azura.
No, don't care.
I'm gonna fart on you most.
Um...
Azura is up and tea...
My man?
Nope, she's not.
She's all sick.
Hmm.
Is she still all sick?
Whoa!
No, hold on a minute now.
I...
Fart?
Wait, you want me to fart?
Oh wait, did I say something about fart?
Oh, we get confused.
We confuse each other so easily.
No, no, no, no.
Uh, Azura didn't stream after me,
which means she thinks she's not well enough to stream today.
Is marriage streaming on a Sunday?
Marriage streaming on the Easter?
Yes, that's how I spell her name.
It's really difficult, okay?
Marriage seems plain and cock.
What the fuck?
It's literally called cock.
Cock shadow of the common.
Why is marriage streaming on cock?
What's going on here?
What is going on here?
No, this is not happening to matters.
Need daughter of mine who's gonna be playing on cock?
Yeah, fuck is that.
It's literally constantly playing with what you love.
Oh, join her?
Marriage streaming later, but it's in seven hours.
What? I'm not allowed to read her, right?
It's like that far away.
Uh, well, I'm not allowed to read her right that far away.
It's red.
I'm not allowed to read her right.
No, no, no, no, no.
What wants in my life?
Why is that?
I don't know what that song is.
What is this?
Read her.
I hardly, well, I do, who wants to actually.
I don't rather wow.
This Smith.
Hold on, pull up the lyrics right now.
You're getting an impromptu, terrial paper one.
You're getting an acapella.
What wants in my life?
Please let me get what I want.
Okay, okay, we got it.
Okay, I've got the lyrics.
So for once in my life
Let me get what I want.
Lord knows it will be the first time.
I don't know the next part after that.
But there you go.
Right, yes, I'm going to redirect into Merchley Sheen.
It's like, I don't care.
I don't care, okay?
I don't care.
I'm going to redirect into a seven hour stream.
So seven hours away, okay?
A meal and a show.
It is a meat, coffee.
Oh, master.
I don't know what.
Wait, the maid cafe is saying to you.
How do you say master in Japanese again?
Obasa?
No, no, that's wrong.
Oh, no, the word is as well.
Because I've seen it in so much hentai.
What is it?
Gojijisa.
Okay, okay, okay, good.
Okay, we're leaving.
Gojijisa.
Gojijisa?
That's fucking too many syllables.
Okay.
Itadakimasu.
It's cute, isn't it?
Okay, thank you.
Because I masked me for showing up to the cafe.
Sorry, we killed you in the process.
Oh, of course, of course.
Right, I am going to...
Eh, excuse me.
Right, I'm going to redirect into Merchley Sheen.
Give me five minutes to clean up.
I will do a membership eight some more after and I'm actually going to try hard.
Yes, I'll be miserable.
No, I don't care.
You need an audio in that voice.
I mean, she...
Why not?
Okay, give me...
Give me, give me, give me...
Alright, give me five minutes.
And if not, I'll see you tomorrow for some...
Sonny heroes, Sonny heroes
Baby, baby, baby, baby, baby
That's the song, thank you, thank you
Okay, I see you very shortly
Good boy, I'll see you in a moment
I love you
I'm sorry I killed you with waffles
Okay, I paid you, I paid you, I paid you